Actor Todd Lawson LaTourrette's status as
a war veteran and amputee has helped him carve
out a decent career in Hollywood.
It's a somewhat unconventional angle, but
it worked for LaTourrette, who has scored
small parts in big films like the George Clooney
war comedy The Men Who Stare at Goats, as
well as roles in series like Netflix's modern
Western crime drama Longmire.
"Got a lot of old regulars up here.
Ah!
Here he is."
And, most recently, LaTourrette appeared in
the critically acclaimed Better Call Saul.
Fans of the Breaking Bad spin-off series will
recognize LaTourrette from the season 4 episode
"Quite a Ride," which aired on AMC on September
3rd.
LaTourrette scored the gig due in part to
his missing appendage, which he previously
claimed was the unfortunate outcome of an
injury he sustained while serving overseas.
However, it turns out, that was a total lie.
Speaking with Albuquerque NBC-affiliate KOB
4, LaTourrette revealed that he isn't really
a war veteran, and that he didn't lose his
hand and part of his arm during active duty.
In reality, he cut off and cauterized his
own hand and then lied about his identity
as a military vet in the hopes of landing
roles in film and on television.
LaTourrette's lies helped him achieve his
goal, but the guilt his fibbing left him with
far outweighs the benefits he's reaped.
LaTourette explained that the incident took
place in 2001, when he wasn't taking medications
meant to help him manage his bipolar disorder.
He told the station,
"I severed my own hand with a skill saw.
The state of my mind was a psychotic episode."
He added that Hollywood believed his story
and nobody questioned how he became an amputee,
and he was seen as a unique casting opportunity.
His missing limb and how his character lost
it was even a plot point in this episode of
The CW's supernatural drama The Messengers:
"How exactly did you lose it?
Your arm?"
"I was riding shotgun in a Humvee in Kandahar.
The attention and praise may have felt good
in the moment, but it didn't last forever,
and left LaTourrette feeling guilty.
LaTourette, who is reportedly back on his
bipolar disorder medication as of the making
of this video, noted that he's fully aware
of the consequences and fallout that will
result from his confession, but felt it was
crucial to come clean.
"I'm ousting myself from the New Mexico Film
Industry.
And gladly so, just to say what I've said."
He was also candid in stating that he doesn't
expect anyone to forgive him for his wrongdoings,
but he remains hopeful that him opening up
about his struggles with mental illness and
the extremes his bipolar disorder drove him
to will motivate others to seek help if they
need it.
"The power is in your hands to take that medication
in the morning, or at night.
So that, this, this discourse of my life doesn't
need to necessarily be yours."
If you or someone that you know is struggling
with mental illness, call the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services Administration's
national helpline at 1-800-662-HELP, visit
the National Institute of Mental Health online
at the address on your screen, or call the
National Suicide Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-273-8255.